this is an interview with jonathan pajot
who invited me into his home
though i released it about two years ago
was conducted two years ago
but i'm embarrassed about it and ashamed
even
because i was younger and nervously
interrupting in an attempt to try and
impress
jonathan which is a quality or
characteristic that was
there when i interviewed janice fiamengo
as well in the janusz mango interview
which is also on this channel
it's not surprising because it was
recorded day afterward however many of
you enjoyed it at the time it had a 98.5
like ratio and i'm reposting it because
of that
i have a larger audience now and perhaps
many more people now will benefit from
jonathan's words
jonathan pejo is wonderful in the
interview there are what are called math
prodigies
child prodigies in math what they are
generally are people who at a young age
can take numbers
large numbers sum them multiply them
divide them in their head rapidly
jonathan is like that with symbolism
he's able to watch a movie and almost
instantaneously deconstruct it his
channel the symbolic world will have you
question
the distinction between the literal and
the metaphoric which
actually means it helps you or imposes
a questioning of reality upon you this
can be either for good or for ill
i think it's for good and if you make an
assessment based on the comments and the
people he's influenced
you would say it's for good as well he's
a talented figure and for those of you
who know ramanajan
he's ramanujan the ramanujan of the
symbolism world
he came pretty much from nowhere with no
formal training
and has a pretty natural ability in this
domain as an aside this was for a
documentary called better left unsaid
which i directed
and is actually released now so you can
go to betterleftonsaidfilm.com
to see the version with jonathan pajot
in it you can also watch it on itunes
and so on but
the director's version the one that has
jonathan in it the one that's more
sesquipedalian and even mystical that
one is on
betterleftonsetfilm.com thank you and if
you enjoy seeing conversations like this
then please do consider
going to patreon.com and supporting you
can make a custom pledge
literally each dollar there's that word
literally
literally each dollar makes a difference
financially as well as
motivationally it may even help
metaphorically please enjoy the
interview despite my
asinine and unpolished likely still
unpolished interview skills
thank you i'm here with the preeminent
the exigent the pivotal
paramount paramount jonathan pageau
artist
carver public speaker symbolic
translator i guess yeah you could say
that something like that
why don't you just tell me about what
you do tell
everybody about what you do but tell me
all right well i
um i'm mostly an artist i make religious
art liturgical art you could call it
in the orthodox tradition but in general
in let's say the kind of christian
medieval tradition
and that has led me to look into
symbolism
in the christian tradition but also in
general looking at other
religions other traditions but through
other types of storytelling as well
fairy tales
mythology and now modern storytelling
such as movies and novels and everything
and so looking into symbolic structures
relating to
my art has led me to becoming
becoming interested in symbolism in
general
and so in my daily practice by making
making icons
i engage in that world let's say that
symbolic world through
my art making and then the way that that
art integrates into the life of a church
in the life of a community is also part
of that but then
now for the past i guess two years now
i've been doing a lot more of public
speaking
talking about symbolism in general how
it relates to our life how it
its structures are the um inform
our perception of reality and are
interacting with reality so that's what
i've been doing
through youtube but also doing a lot of
public speaking all over north america
for the past two years now you said that
you got started because you're an artist
and so you started
studying the symbolic representations
and what they mean but
give me a timeline of your life so you
were four years old and you started this
and then you were well i know i
when i was young i always kind of knew i
was going to be an artist
from when i was pretty young but then i
was also
my parents were a christian i was a
christian i was part of a evangelical
church and then when i studied uh in
college when i studied at concord
university painting and drawing i really
hit a wall it was just contemporary art
is
an art which is very removed from what
it's doing you know it's like a comment
upon a comment upon a comment isn't it
all right is that another word for
modern art or is that different
well contemporary art you would say
you could you could use modern for the
whole period but usually we use the word
modern for
the early 20th century up to about world
war ii
and then after world war ii we start to
talk about moving towards what we could
call post-modern art or contemporary
art which is even more let's say removed
from um more a comment like i said a
comment upon a comment it becomes about
art itself
it becomes a kind of circular uh
playing with elements uh so the art
piece of art that was just a urinal
yes well that was modern well that was
modern but duchamp who made that
urinal is seen as a one of the seminal
figures in
bringing about what would be today
installation art and
contemporary art so there are certain
figures in modernism which
lead into what we now consider people
like jeff koons or
andy warhol you know they they take
their
their drive from peop from from uh
people like marcel duchamp's beginning
of the century so it was already
already there at the beginning of the
century let's say everything was kind of
packaged up and then it
unfurled itself into now the kind of
on one hand anything goes but on the
other hand
everything has to be packaged in a a
kind of
post-cynical uh you know ironic
double irony triple irony so that's
really what it is so it was very
difficult for me
coming in as someone who wanted to
connect with reality
you know who who as a person of faith i
wanted to make things which
which weren't just this flighty irony
you know of
of of references but wanted to connect
with something real
and so i was just hitting a wall i just
couldn't couldn't make it happen
i got interested in some contemporary
artists for example there's a german
artist
his name is anselm kiefer and he was the
closest to what i was hoping to do he
was he was trying to bring back
mythological thinking within the artwork
but his work was still it's still
problematic because it's still in
galleries it's still prestige objects
objects which have no function in the
world right we're actually
so used to thinking that art doesn't
have a function in the world
that we forget that traditional arts in
in
all cultures actually have uh functions
within the community they they integrate
themselves within a world view within a
a community living um and so and is that
conscious
do they consciously construct the arts
so that they're integrating one another
or does that happen
because they're communally putting
together a piece of art and then they
all
respect it and revere it and it has
their values embedded in it somehow
well the traditional way of seeing art
is very different from the contemporary
way of seeing art
the way that traditional vision pretty
much i would say worldwide
you see art as a skill and so the notion
of art
is we still use that word today when we
say the art of cheese making
or the art of this the art of that and
so that that's really the traditional
way of understanding the word art the
word art actually means in latin
comes from the notion of fitting things
together so the capacity to fit things
together properly that's what art is
and so in a traditional vision of art we
we say things like uh the art remains
with the artist
right the art is the skill of making
things and so the
the object that is made has to serve a
purpose there's no such thing
in a traditional vision as making art
you don't make art you use art to make
things and so the art is the tool art is
the tool art is the skill art is the
the capacity that you have mastered to
make an object
and so then that object needs to have a
function in the world it needs to be
integrated within a purpose
and that's probably one of the hardest
things for people to understand
is that art is not a value in itself
and once you understand that at least
when i understood that
it actually liberated my me from a lot
of problems because
one of the problems we're always asking
is is this art
is this art you know you you they they
come up with some crazy
jeff coons you know blown up uh snoopy
and then the question is is that art
and the answer to me now has become i
don't care
that's that doesn't matter that's not
the point the whether it's art or not
that's not that's not a question
the question is does it does it matter
does it have meaning
does it have a function is it is it
integratable into society like does it
have
a capacity to integrate into the world
um
and so when i all of this was kind of
playing around in my head
while i was studying fine art and it was
so funny because
it was so taking that that became the
subject of my art and so
the subject of my art in college was
how can i make art in this post-modern
world which
is not just ironic which is actually
connected to
a community to a to to let's say a
coherent world view
but then it was it was still being very
removed it was like
i'm not doing it i'm asking myself
whether i can do it
and it was so funny because the last
my last uh day in school when my
supervisor was giving me my final grade
she said uh
it was so funny because i actually
finished first in my program like i was
really diligent i was working hard but
she knew that it just wasn't it wasn't
working and she uh
she just looked at me and said don't
worry you're getting all a's it's okay
what did she know was not working
well she understood that if what i was
trying to do
which is for example to be a christian
person
who was making art in a manner which was
authentic uh and but was still
somehow part of the contemporary art
world which is full of irony and full of
double uh let's say double removal and
constant
you know a kind of flighty removed
version of reality
she just knew that it it wasn't wasn't
happening
and so she just she just told me on the
very last day of my of my degree she
said
what are you doing here like you don't
you don't belong here you should go to
seminary or something
you know because you're too traditional
no because she could see that
the questions i was asking were not they
just it just wasn't
fitting with the with the contemporary
art world it just didn't have its place
the questions such as such as the
utility of asking whether or not a piece
of art is a piece of art
no no not that that that is something
that everybody is
always constantly asking the the problem
was mostly
to say how can i let's say as part of a
community
let's say a part of a christian
community how can i make
objects which fit into my life and into
my world and into my community
in a in an integrated way you know like
i mean it really is a difference between
i didn't know yet because i hadn't
discovered traditional art it really is
the difference between let's say
i make you're a musician and you come to
me
and you say here's my here's what i'm
trying to play this is what i'm doing
then i i uh i design a guitar for
your particular needs that's traditional
art
right um but and the post modern version
of that would be the postmodern version
of that would be i will make
a guitar that will question what a
guitar is right i will make a guitar
that cannot cannot
be played but will will ironically
question the whole tradition of what
of what guitars have been and what music
and and then now today it's even worse
because now it's going to show
how the the guitar itself as an object
who's created
by by hierarchies of uh of historical
hierarchies
how does it how is it a uh uh an object
which
which manifests or subverts that
hierarchy you know um
that's the that's the difficulty of post
modernism so that so i would that's not
what i was
wanting to do you know that that's not
that's not what i was trying to do i was
trying to
create a lang visual language which was
which would
integrate with my own experience with my
own faith with my own
participation in a community in the
church and all that okay let's get back
we're going to get back to this but
let's get back to
art as a tool yeah so you're saying art
is a tool so this snoopy
example i don't know the reference i
don't know jeff coons is big snoopy yeah
well i don't think he made a big sober
he made he makes like for example he did
uh he did a big
a big sculpture which is a a pile of
play-doh
so likely imagine like a lot a small
child has taken bits of play-doh and you
just kind of jump
bundle up in a thing he made a giant
bronze uh sculpture of uh
of of a pile of play-doh okay example
that's jeff koons okay so it makes
things like that so this amalgamation of
plato
is it art and you're quite your answer
is it doesn't matter
what matters more as doesn't matter and
doesn't provide meaning to a certain
set of people and does it integrate that
people with the community
i don't know if i'm yeah it's something
like that how does it integrate into
the world how does it participate in the
world how does it
build instead of and that i think that
then if it does
then it's art or no it's not working
forget about the question of whether
the art itself is the skill right it's
the capacity to do that
that's what that's that's the
traditional worldview so all right so
let's take another example let's say
someone's making
someone's a great pizza maker yeah and
then they make something let's
say they made it out of pizza but
they're good pizza makers so then the
question is is that pizza and you would
say
well did they use the skill of pizza
making on that object the question would
be is it good
because that's what it pizza's supposed
to do so can you eat it yes and does it
taste good
if you want to know if whether or not
that that
that pizza maker is a good artist is
whether or not the pizza does what the
pizza is supposed to do which just
tastes good
you know whatever it is it could it
could be to be healthy too it depends on
what the the pizza maker wants to
accomplish by making his pizza
you know it's the same thing with
someone like i said somebody would make
a musical instrument
the question if you ask whether or not
that that
uh you know the the musical instrument
maker
is a good artist is whether or not that
instrument does what it's supposed to do
um and that's it's very difficult for
people to think that way now
you know because even in the past music
was composed for reasons
we don't people didn't just compose
music just to compose music
they would compose music for a requiem
music for a mass music for a
feast music to celebrate uh someone's
birthday to celebrate the king
to to uh the music was written
to integrate into society it would you
wouldn't just
write unless you were making studies or
maybe you were studying to practice or
you're doing things like that
but your ultimate purpose was to write a
a uh a piece of music which would which
would
function you know even storytelling
that's been a while since we've had that
but
even storytelling in a traditional sense
like if you think of the great epics if
you think of
of the iliad or the the odyssey those
were
community building stories those stories
were meant to
create to even create what the greeks
were
so how do you judge a piece of art where
the artist themselves doesn't know what
the purpose of the piece of art was
what do you mean how do you like they
it's because you're saying you can posit
a goal and then
whether or not you achieve that goal
through the art that's
a measure of the arts it's not it's not
necessarily what
worth you could you could go further
than think that it's just based on the
individual's
purpose it's it's a it's a broader thing
than that it's like
if you let's say a pizza maker decided
you wanted to make a pizza in the table
by the way all pizza makers i'm sure
there's a technical term for you
and i apologize i know you're just in
you're greeting yourself
so let's say a pizza maker decided he
wanted to make a pizza that tastes bad
you know he could do that but it would
probably not be considered great pizza
and that guy would probably not be
considered
a good pizza artist okay but in there in
that example it's obvious what the
intention of the pizza is it's to be
eaten but say someone like picasso and
he just goes in a room he doesn't know
what he's doing
he organizes his room so now he's like
maybe i'm an interior decorator oh i
just discovered cubism somehow in his
room but he doesn't know what it's for
yeah because he doesn't know what it's
for we also don't know what it's for
because the artist was just
exploring and they created something
yeah so
can we judge it then because we don't
know its purpose well i think that
picasso and modern art in general has a
has a destabilizing effect on society
and i think they meant for it to be that
so in a way maybe they did what they did
was right
i think that most modern art and
contemporary art
believes in a revolutionary vision of
reality that the purpose
that our purpose is to is to to bring
about revolutions to
to destroy the the the status quo to
destroy
the existing order and and i think that
picasso was a communist i mean he was a
communist pretty much his whole life
even
even when it became embarrassing maybe
to be so and uh
a lot of the a lot of the modern artists
were either communists or fascists
you know these the futurists were
straight on fascists you know they
wanted
to burn the old system down and set up a
totalitarian
uh you know system of art too a
totalitarian system of art we have
artists who were totalitarian in their
artistic vision
we don't we don't tend to want to see
them that way now for some reason
but uh but the uh a lot of the the the
abstract artists were
especially the russian abstract artists
had a totalitarian vision of reality
and a lot of modern designers were very
totalitarian you know
some some modern architects would say
things like
you know i wish i could design the
people in my house or i wish i could
nail the chairs to the floor
so that i could control sounds like
excess order exactly
everything the way the way it is okay um
and so you have these
these you have like the this you have
this these two tendencies let's say
modern art you have both you have
a kind of destructive tendency and a
totalitarian tendency which is part of
the modern world so you see it as
off-balance because yeah in peter's
the pedersonian point of view which is
also the dallas point of view there's
order chaos and you see it as being on
the extremes and that they're not
mediating between the two
properly yeah i agree i think the whole
modern world
that's what it is it's just a swing it's
just this
this uh pendulum swing between two two
excesses and you can see it in modern
art you can see it as well
and they become confused and they kind
of fight and then they they break each
other apart
but but it's a it is a fascinating thing
to to see now we kind of just gloss over
a lot of it
but if you look at the way for example
that even
post um abstract expressionist art
uh let's say manifested itself it
started with this
freeing up you know jackson pollock
throwing paint on the ground and
and kind of this chaotic energy and
everything and then it ended
with color field painting where it was
like just
strips of one color and you couldn't do
anything else like it was
it was uh completely everything was
controlled in these extremely
tight tight boxes of what you could do
and i saw this painting that was just
white with one speck of red do you know
this painting i forget it's a
large it's a very famous painting yeah i
don't know which i don't know which
painting you're for that
okay just imagine a blanket yes i can
imagine that and then there's some
splotch of red in the corner yeah and it
sold for millions of dollars
is that contemporary yeah well that's it
depends it could be
uh it would probably be a moderate we
probably considered modern or late
modern you could say
contemporary arts tends to be more uh
cynical
and and we'll take modern conventions
and be more playful about them
and will create a kind of parody for
example uh
a german artist like uh richter who is
an abstract artist but his abstract art
is considered to be a kind of
parody of abstract art where it's a it's
almost like a comment on
abstract art it's not directly abstract
art it looks like abstract art with a
kind of photo
kind of weird photo uh lack of focus in
it
and there's a lot of neo abstract
artists who are actually
there's a kind of weird cynicism to what
they're doing but it gets very confusing
contemporary art right now is just a
giant ball of anything like you it's
very
difficult to know there is a post
post-modern or at least
i think no i think that we have i think
that what i'm doing is
is could be considered post-post-modern
and
i'm part of a group let's say of people
who have
grown up in contemporary art who learn
contemporary art
several who are who had a promising
contemporary art career ahead of them
you know they had
they were in galleries they had um they
had different
uh scholarships and everything to big
schools but then
they kind of came to the end of the kind
of say like they came to the end of the
carnival
at some point the carnival has to end
you know at some point
you've eaten enough pie and you're
you're you know you've had enough
uh you had enough pizza had enough pizza
exactly you had enough uh
sugar and and and and blinking lights
and so
what ends up happening is a rediscovery
of
what i would call traditional art and i
and i see that you see that
so so i know several iconographers who
make icons for churches
who who had that exact turn where they
came to the end of contemporary art and
they realized
this is this is just nihilism it's just
nihilism on steroids
and so they they re-embrace let's say
the traditional language of
of the church something doesn't happen
within a
field of modern okay so there's
modernism there's post-modernism then
there's traditionalism
now does this cycle happen even within
a section so there's the section of
traditional intersection of modernism
and post-modernism
or does it happen within i think that
happened
as with the sections as a whole well the
problem the problem with the
contemporary art world
is that the very setup of the
contemporary art world is
is not conducive for it within that
world for
let's say a return to order to happen or
a let's say a a post-post modernism to
happen
because you you have a a return to the
proper balance between order and chaos
because as you were saying can't just be
returned to order because the fascists
had extreme order
right for them it would be returned to
the middle exactly
the problem is that's true in the modern
one of the things we forget about
modernism
is there is another wing of modernism
which we don't
tend to to uh to think of which is
social realism
and social realism is has been used
very much as a just pure propaganda like
just a pure propaganda tool
because it's whole style its whole
affectations are basically you know a
kind of um
sentimentality you know a kind of going
in to get your sense of nationalism or
your sense of
of uh of uh of courage or whatever
and so they they tend to push you
towards um
towards uh propaganda so what people
traditionally think of as propaganda is
social realism
i i mean usually those are the things
like these nazi propagandists yes they
are and
the same with uh the same with the
russians like the russians had
a whole tradition of of social realism i
mean jordan peterson has
has collected them his house is full of
of social of
russian social realism where the purpose
of these paintings is to
make you a good citizen right to make
you participate in in
uh in the state do you see elements of
social realism in the modern films
that we have now like mona i think it's
called mona
the one that you analyze mona moana and
then
frozen and then wonder woman yeah
well right now we we don't i would say
that we're not we're not using social
realism for our propaganda anymore
the uh because it's a different it's a
weird different
um it's a weird different world than
than for example early century
early one of the things that has
happened
is let's say
the revolutionary elements of our
society they they've actually
understood symbolism they've been the
ones who for the past let's say 50 years
have understood symbolism the most and
so
they've actually been using
let's say mythological structures to
affect to you to affect their propaganda
it's very different
much like the nazi symbol being what
what was it swastika was what yeah
was it i mean the swastika is one of the
most ancient images
one of the most ancient symbols that
exist it's it's uh
it's an image that is universal you
could find it in all cultures uh
you can find it in you can go to a
church medieval church and see swastikas
you can go to a hindu temple and see
swastikas
it is it's probably one of the oldest
images we have
and so they were able to to to take it
to
to to change it a little bit they made
it uh
instead of making it straight they
slanted it i think that it's in
the nazis are a really good example in a
way in the sense that the nazis
they wanted to co-op mythological
thinking more than others
they had a weird they also they had a
weird uh
religious feel to them right they they
had that kind of strange esoteric
and uh you know a desire to renew to
revive
uh northern gods they also had weird
contacts with uh
with uh indian the the the uh the
aristocracy in india with the uh um
what are the names of the the cast and i
can't remember anything in the cast um
so do you think that's one of the
reasons why why these totalitarian
regimes when they come in particularly
on the left so particularly communist
regimes
that they want to obliterate traditional
art and obliterate
religion and ban it oh for sure because
they understand it
well they because they they understand
how potent it is
and also because especially the
communists the communist uh
groups they really wanted to because
they believe that the human person
is malleable right that we're a blank
slate type
and so what they they wanted to destroy
the
all the cultural tenets which were there
in order to bring about their utopia
you know the chinese the russians did it
too the russians liquidated
they destroyed the russians destroyed
over 30 000 churches
just during the the early times of
stalin
and you know we all know that the maoist
cultural revolution was insane
you know they just went around
destroying not only destroying but
execute
executing anybody that had to do with
the priesthood yeah and the same thing i
mean or buddhists
really early communists or russia
russians would go around you know
and just just to shoot priests in the
head you know it was a cra it was an
insane time so it's like liquidating
the the uh the imagery in order to bring
about their
their utopia but today we
today it's weird it's different our our
version of that let's say our
version of propaganda is a little
different from that it's more
it's more insipid and it's more it tends
to understand like i said it tends to be
more subversive
rather than directly offensive in in the
sense that
it's better to instead of
it's better to show like the show in
versions and to to to to have stories
with
the notion that the inverted is becomes
the
norm in a way and that seems to be the
way to that that a lot of
propaganda is happening now um and so
it's it's a bit different and so
sometimes it's tricky because sometimes
the stories actually end up looking very
much
like ancient traditional stories it's
often just that they're upside down or
that there's a like shrek is a great
example
shrek is like the most the easiest
example to see
where it looks like a fairy tale but
it's actually an upside down it's a
totally upside down fairy tale where you
have an ogre
ogre and a princess you know the ogre is
this monster and they they present them
as a monster
so that would be an example of a
post-modern film yeah of an upside-down
fairy tale
of a subversive use of traditional
tropes
where all the tropes are there but
they're just totally upside down
you know the ogre is represented as a
monster he
suggested it suggests that he's a
cannibal he suggests all these things
that the normal
ogre is and then he meets a princess and
in the end the princess becomes an ogre
and it's like okay the shape of water is
a great example too recent more recent
version
where all the normative characters you
know the
the christian the the the the the white
male
all that they're all absolutely evil
okay and uh
and then all the kind of exceptional
characters like the monster
and then all these other exceptional
categories are somehow pure and innocent
and all of that
and then in the end the the the woman
becomes becomes a monster like that's
how it ends she goes into the water she
becomes a sea monster
and it's like we're so used to it we
think that somehow that that's a normal
way
for a story to go but it's very
disturbing you know
enormous i've seen that so much in the
past 15 years yeah and a normal story
like the story of the frog and the
princess for example is that
the exceptional character the frog this
talking frog who's a monster
is by some proof of their virtue
integrated into the world right little
mermaid becomes a human
yeah well that's a difficult thing
becomes a human yeah pano is a yeah
that's
that's a good that's a good example you
know miyazaki i've been watching
miyazaki films because you commented on
spirited away and i wanted to watch it
again so i started watching a few
and i was trying to put my finger on why
is it so it's
it's damn good his films are very good
and i realized not only
are they magical and whimsical like a
child and an imaginative
but there's a complete lack of cynicism
yeah a complete lack of sarcasm
sarcasm or or sardonic commentary yeah
no that's i think you really put your
finger on it
and i think that because we're in a
situation
because of our because of technology and
because of
our extremely ordered societies where we
have a
you know everything is controlled by the
state basically not everything but
so much of our world is controlled by
the state and by these giant
corporations and everything
we have a need for feminine symbolism
we have a need for the private sphere we
have a need for
the refreshing aspect of of our personal
relationships all this feminine
symbolism
we have a desire and a need for it and
the thing about miyazaki is that
almost all his films take on this
feminine symbolism but he does it in
such a beautiful
way where he doesn't feel the need to be
subversive or to kind of show how you
know the male character is an idiot or
or or yeah there's useless there's a
complete absence or lack
of a political message oh yeah no i
think the closest maybe
ponyo where he says the humans are
ruining the earth right with their ships
that's the closest that i found so far
but i agree i agree that that's what
makes him so strong and that's why and
they make him so strong also because
he's able
to create strong female characters but
in a manner which is not
doesn't it doesn't have that kind of
anger and bitterness and cynicism in it
where it's more like a celebration of
of these beautiful feminine characters
and it doesn't make the feminine the
masculine
it doesn't make a girl have
traditionally masculine qualities and
then say
we're subverting notions of gender yeah
because that's what i mean that's what
so many of the the like the superhero
moves that we've seen recently and
a lot of the like the star wars movies
and everything is and i think that's why
people are
are kind of annoyed with them is because
they're
it's not only the desire to make let's
say a
feminine care a female character into
the same action hero
that we've had you know since the 1980s
that everybody's criticized
like it's you know it's the feminist or
you know the the postmodern criticized
that figure of the
of this of the hero of the male hero and
so but now you want to make a woman into
it
masculinity is toxic as long as it's a
male exactly
like masculinity becomes good if it's a
female who embodies it
it's just completely it's completely
upside down and here's what else what
else does i find funny about that
then feminine femininity is just
unattractive when it's attached to a
male so as a male you can't win
it's very difficult if you're if you're
a masculine so but if you're attractive
and you're
toxic and you have toxic masculinity you
can get away with almost anything yeah
we had this conversation with janice
fiamango that the people who are getting
who are getting sent letters saying stop
what you're doing
is are they tend to be people who are
unattractive yeah males
yeah exactly if you were an attractive
male then the woman wouldn't find it
catcalling she would find it no i
totally agree
who's that who's the british comedian
there that jordan did an interview with
i forget his name
the this one british comedian
he's milo no no he's he jordan jordan
did
i think he was like he was like a huge
deal and he he came to press and
everything
he did an interview with sam harris and
he did interview with jordan he's kind
of on board with intel intellectual dark
anyways he was like he was this super
good looking guy and
he was extremely promiscuous you know
and just
had loads and loads of sex all kinds of
women and i saw russell brown yeah
russell brent i saw him once
meeting with a woman talking to her and
he reached back behind her back and he
undid her bra like
that and oh and everybody was laughing
and she was laughing and she's like oh
what did you do it's so funny
and like really interesting you know
imagine if anybody else had done that
you know what it would have been and i'm
just i mean i i'm figuring like maybe
russell ren at some point you're
to turn on him when he kind of when he
loses his attractive edge
they might turn on him at some point but
uh yeah and i agree that it's mostly
that that certain behaviors uh let's say
trying to trying to be flirty with a
woman if you're good-looking and you're
into you're desirable then that's not a
problem but if you're ugly
let's get to lord of the rings all right
lord of the rings i want you to tell me
the story of no don't tell me the story
is gonna take hours and hours
tell me the symbolism behind the ring
well the ring the ring is really power i
mean it's called the ring of power
uh but i think that the ring is is
the power in the sense that we
understand it today in in the sense of
technological power that is the capacity
to
affect the world right so it could be
political as well
but a good way to understand it is is
technological power
in the sense that it's it's a it's the
the capacity to control to affect
uh things around you and so the ring
itself
this symbol of metallurgy is a very
ancient symbol of exactly that
right in the bible you have this notion
that as the fall of man
kind of increases moving towards the
flood one of the steps
is the creation of of met of metallurgy
with two balcane
and the forging of weapons but then
it's there in other traditions as well
and other somebody was telling me a
nordic tradition about almost the same
idea that
the and in greek in greek uh thinking
you know uh
hephaestus the god of uh metallurgy is a
he's a
he's kind of like a monstrous deformed
god who who was kicked out of
uh the the the olympia of olympus
and lives in a kind of dark fiery place
and that's where he makes his
and so it's like this it's kind of like
an image of the capacity
on the margin to to uh
to control the the the outside you could
say something like that
does that make sense yeah yeah yeah and
then you're saying how
the the ring becoming something that
makes you invisible
makes sense because right well
the the idea is that you have to
understand it
you have to understand technology or if
you have to understand power
or capacity to move out into the margin
you have to understand it as adding
layers
to yourself right that's that's a good
way to understand technology you could
add the supplement so you supplement
your existence
with something so you know you wear
clothes
you add a layer of clothes because and
then you can live further out right you
used to be
only to live on the equator now you can
live further out from the equator
because you have clothes and you can
keep warm
then you develop houses you develop
develop different technologies
to to bolster your capacity to live
further out so imagine now the same
thing in terms of political power
you're one person what can you do you
can't do much so you
you you in becoming in adding power to
yourself
let's say you you hire an army you hire
you get weapons
you put on an armor you do all these
things you learn to ride a horse you
have all these things that you add to
yourself in order to make yourself
more powerful right and
the ultimate example of that is the
ornament
so we often don't think what a
metaphysically what an ornament is
but an ornament is something that you
add to
another thing to make it just to make it
different just to make it special
right because it has no purpose if i if
i put a if i paint a flower on a chair
it doesn't participate in the chair
nature of the chair doesn't help me sit
on it
that's what you know all it does is it
makes it different from
others and it's the same for people so
so
a woman will wear jewelry a man will
wear
will will wear julie as well a woman
will wear makeup
in order to to to supplement her beauty
you could say so a woman wears me to
supplement her beauty but
what happens is as the supplement gets
stronger and stronger
you the question is are you
supplementing to show
right to to call attention to or are you
supplementing
in order to hide the true nature of what
it is that you're supplementing
right and it it's hard to know when that
happens
right it's hard to know when i take a
hammer
in order to be able to hit nails and and
hit them in
but then at some point the weapon the
technology becomes so big
that it it i could never do it
like it it's actually there to mask my
capacity to
to to do with that that actual action
the same with with makeup you know you
everybody has seen a woman who at some
point in her life as she enters her 50s
or 60s
she doesn't she doesn't realize what's
going on and then she starts to wear too
much
makeup and then you realize that it's
actually there to hide her
her age it's not there to to enhance to
accentuate exactly okay and so that's
how
the ornament makes you invisible is you
you disappear behind the supplement at
some point
so if you if you keep adding those
layers at some point
those layers are all that is it's like a
i see i see so
okay if you have an empty shell so
there's technology i'm just gonna
see if i understand so there's
technology and use that technology to
expand what you can do to expand
your dominion over the world and over
others yeah
then you can also think of it in terms
of makeup as a technology
buying a big car to signal your
attractiveness is a technology in the
sense because
it's a tool so tool is another word for
technology right and
the big car is the great is the great
example right i mean for a man that's a
that's a that's a it's a joke that we
have right
the guy with the with the sports car you
know
is it there to is it there to uh
actually hide something about him
something that he's missing some some
aspect of him which is deficient
and then he's hiding himself behind his
big car he's actually hiding the fact
that he's
i mean this is like the joke right he's
hiding himself
the fact that he's somehow deficient in
some spheres of his love life
with this big car so he's
overcompensating in that manner
and so that's a way for him to hide he's
he's hiding himself behind this this
ring
how does it work when it comes to armies
like let's say you're the president of
the united states
and you just keep ex you keep pumping
money into the military
so you're expanding your range of
dominion yeah how does that relate to
hiding um
let's try to understand it in terms of
in terms of an army
um because i understand it in terms of
masking when it comes to something like
makeup or the man with the car
or someone with extremely well
someone who's extremely well-dressed but
to the point of not being well to being
overly dressed
well i would say i would say we could
see some examples i think
in terms of when
is it that uh let's say
civilizations become expansive
um i mean i think a lot of people could
argue with me
on on this for sure okay
but i think that if you look at
the the uh the expansion of
the roman empire for example the
question is why did it expand
like why why would it expand and one of
the answers
could be exactly what i said it could be
exactly that it is lacking
within itself what it needs to exist and
so it has to
has to eat has to speed up how what what
it's eating
on the outside it has to kind of devour
the outside it and add add add add
add add to a point where it always feels
like
it it's it's um
it's pushing away the moment where it's
going to break apart
by doing that because it's there's
something in the center
which is lacking there's some there's
some inner thing which is lacking
and you see that i mean i think that we
see that and we could think about in
terms of materialism how people
will start to buy buy buy things because
there's something lacking
within themselves and so they do that in
a way to make them feel like they're
like they're still growing okay so they
lack something crucial that will help
them survive and so they stave off the
inevitable
by increasing their imperialistic powers
that's something that the communists did
yeah i think so i think that that's a
good way to understand it in terms of
of of empires that tend to oh i mean
that's
one example because others could just
simply be greed
yeah but i think that greed is that
greed is that too
i think that this this that's true
because greed could also be tied to an
insecurity
which means you don't have something
that's right and so that's why the ring
is related to our desires uh
this periphery this idea of supplement
is also related to what the christians
would call the passions
so you have these you have these things
that pull you from the outside desires
you know
gluttony uh pride uh sexual desire all
these things
and so if if you move in that direction
usually that's what it is you're devour
you're eating
you're you're taking in things you're
you're acting in certain ways in order
to compensate
for something that you're lacking
interior interiorly
you know and everybody knows someone who
does that i mean you can take extreme
cases of someone that say who drinks
you know and you know and you know
someone who who becomes an alcoholic
he doesn't just become an alcoholic
because of alcohol
right usually you become an alcoholic
you you drink to
fill up some malaise that you have some
kind of and everybody has
that malaise you know we just do we have
different ways of dealing with it
but you you can you engage in certain
supplementary behaviors
in order to and the supplement because
the sublime is also medicine
that's also important and understanding
this idea of supplement
is uh it also has to do with
with the notion of taking in something
or
intoxicants or medicine all of that is
part of this notion of the supplement
because when you're sick you have to
take something from the outside
in order to heal you and it works like
it can work you know and the supplement
is not
there's nothing wrong about the
supplement there's nothing wrong about
this process
it's just that it can become out of
control you know because you need to eat
and and there's nothing wrong with with
sexual activity all those things are
fine it's just that
if you fall you can fall into a a
you can fall into a pattern where that
behavior or that
that that desire or or you know the
alcohol or drugs or whatever it is or
power or
all the things that we do or buying cars
or you know whatever it is that we do to
supplement our existence
takes you away from yourself and then
you lose yourself in that you
you know you lose yourself in your in
your desires and you you cease to
you've lost the heart like you've lost
the memory of the heart you could call
it
how does this relate to the ring
becoming heavier well i think that
the ring becomes heavier as if you
understand it as
let's say frodo is moving out into that
chaotic world and so it has to become
heavier
in a certain way just like you need to
add more and more layers the further
away you get
from yourself so it's going to be you
know it's like you have to need a bigger
bigger gun a bigger sword a bigger you
know a bigger army a bigger
house a you know a more technology you
if you
going out into space is the ultimate
example you know like you go out into
space you need a massive shell
around you a massive massive shell to
protect you
from the outside because the outside
will kill you um
and i think that that's what that's
what's happening in the lord of the
rings is that
as frodo is moving away from his home as
he's moving away from his
family his identity and all of that and
he's moving out towards this
this dark place then his the ring gets
heavier and it
takes a toll on him you know at first he
has
enough innocence to to bear the ring
without being completely taken over but
as he
moves out and further and further and
further out then it starts to
to eat away at him you know and the only
character in lord of the rings who can
handle the ring without a problem is is
tom bombadil
and that's because he is a
representation of that natural
kind of innocence that kind of
boisterous uh
self fullness of being you know he
doesn't he doesn't he he's a
he's a he has a kind of joyful innocence
that
means that he's not tempted by the the
the the the uh the periphery are tempted
by that a good example is in the movie
spirited away it's a great example
where the the central character what is
her name again
forget her name anyways the the sen but
that was what she was given
yeah well sen yeah she she herself has
that
innocence and so when when she's
she's not in danger the same way that
others are
in that world of uh gold and of
pleasures
and of uh you know this this this uh
this house of
of uh kind of sensuality she's not she's
not in danger so when the when the
monster
when no face presents her with the gold
she's like
huh but she'll take it if she needs it
right and it's fine she's like oh she
needs she needs the
she needs something from no face she'll
she'll take it she's fine but then he's
like no i want to give you more
i want you to give me more and she's
like why would i want more
i i'm fine i i needed this tool to do
this and i did it
and then i'm done and that was because
she was innocent i think it's because
she has
she had a kind of innocence in the right
way to see innocence a kind of
purity you could say a kind of lack of
uh
self let's say a a
a joyful purity i would i don't know how
else to to say it
we were talking about the little mermaid
before we started filming
and i don't know if you had much time to
think about it before we started filming
but can you comment on how the little
mermaid
has a connection to today right um
well especially if if you're talking
about the movie the little mermaid like
the the disney movie
um i think it's
it's interesting because the little
mermaid
she it's funny because
i maybe i need to make a caveat about
about the little mermaid the first
little mermaid like the one that was
written by hans christian andersen
was really about the incapacity
to cross over it was it was it was
really about
the be happy with what you are
um because she she dies right she can't
she can't cross over into the human
world because
that's not her place right and so the
disney version
is the actual total opposite the disney
version is the very opposite it is the
it is the modern like you can be
whatever you want uh version of that
uh so it's very it's kind of interesting
to first of all to think about the
difference between
the two worlds the worlds of hans
christian andersen and and our world
today
where we have this idea that you can
pretty much just
do whatever you want um but what's
interesting in
in the the scene with the the the witch
what's her name again
ursula ursula uh yeah what is
interesting in that scene is that
ursula is making her feel like she cares
about her right making her feel like
she's this poor this poor thing this
poor victim of her circumstance this
poor
uh and she's like i'm going to i can
offer you what you want i can offer you
your desire
but what you have to give me is is your
voice
is your self basically um and so in a
way
yeah exactly your logos and so in a way
it is
it is an image of of this problem of
desire in that sense
and the problem with that movie is that
in the end she gets
her thing that's the problem it's like
it's that's a bit of that that's more
complicated but but uh
but she she's like you need to sacrifice
your self your logos
in order to get what you desire you know
and that's
that is part of this notion of the
supplement in a sense is that you
you if you if you desire this new car
that's what you really desire
if you if you desire to to have all
these sexual experiences if you desire
to
have a certain lifestyle and that's like
that's when you think that that's what
you are
that's when you lose your logo that's
interesting because you can look at it
from two points of view one is ursula
which you can think of as the radical
left enticing people with
with wish fulfillment i just want your
voice but then on the other side
there's the people who are willing to
give up their voice yeah
who are willing to to give up their
theirs
their logos or their their core their
heart or whatever in order
to get something that they desire
in order to get something that they want
and i think that that's
you know and there's something about
that in the ring too there's something
about that in the notion of the ring in
general
where you know the person who is going
to bear the ring
especially someone who who already has a
purpose that
that they're they're going to be able to
accomplish what they want like if they
have that power
they'll be able to do that but they kind
of have to give up
they have to kind of give up their soul
to to get it and
it's a magical all the magical
transactions in stories are always
kind of like that it's like you know you
you get what you want
but you have to give up something more
profound in order to to get that and we
and i think that you see it you see
people who go through that all the time
people go through that all the time
right they
they the guy who all he wants is to get
his million dollars
and then he sacrifices his family he
sacrifices his relationship with his
wife he sacrifices
the things that are actually very
precious that are really precious
because they constitute your
your being in terms of of a communal
being
and they do that to get what they want
and i think that
in terms of the radical left one of the
problems that we're seeing is that
the radical left has been able to
convince people that they're only
this one aspect of what they want
so someone is like i you know i feel
like i'm
you know that i either i'm just one
thing like i'm this one thing and if i
embrace this one aspect of myself
i will get power like i'll get some
political power uh and i think that
that's
that's dangerous in terms of just normal
people like as a
we're not like i am not just a
a you know i'm not just a man i'm not
just a
carver i'm not just a or if i was if i
was gay i'm not just gay i'm not just
trans i'm not just whatever and i'm not
just a european i'm not
so it's like if you embrace this one
aspect of yourself then all of a sudden
it's like but it there's something
that's how you make a weapon right
that's what a weapon is a weapon is
a point it's like i'm going to push
something into a point then i'm going to
use it as a weapon
and that's how you make a weapon but
that's not the way you make a
a person right you don't make a person
by turning a person into
into a weapon or weaponizing you know
something about yourself because you
lose yourself into that
into in that in that weapon you could
say and you can do it with all kinds of
things right you can
you can you could turn your bitterness
into that you could become your
bitterness
it can become your bitterness and your
parents you know you hate your parents
because of what they did
and your whole life falls into that
bitterness and you make this nice
jagged pointy thing where you all you
exist in is this one
thing about you which is the way your
parents treated you and you you you dive
into that it becomes your
your spear and you you start slashing at
the world with it
and it makes you feel powerful because
it works it actually does give you power
but you lose something in in in the in
the balance
you lose the capacity to become a full
person a total
being i just had a thought about about
giving up what you have in order to get
what you want which is ariel
but nihilists in today's world
give up what they want in order to keep
what they have so they don't want
they'll give up their aspirations like
forget about marriage even though they
actually want it forget about
forget about traditional values even
though they actually want friends and
they would like
maybe a nuclear family or whatever it
may be in order to retain their
worldview what they have
but i think it it has to do also with a
a kind of uh
shortening of not what nihilism tends to
do is it tends to
shorten the the horizon you could say
and so the most immediate things we have
are these desires right those are the
most immediate
the idea of wanting a family you have to
you have to like
swim over that first wave which is i
just want to have a beer
right you have to swim over that in
order to to get to something which is
more purposeful and so i think that what
nihilism does is it
it opens up the possibility of just
living in
more immediate desires uh you know
playing video games all day or whatever
it is that you want to do in the
immediate
and not feel like you have to to
to direct yourself towards something
which is higher um
and so in that sense i think that that's
what that's what nihilism tends to do to
people
so what do the hostile brothers cain
enable
their others which i can't think of
right now but what do they have to tell
us about our current situation with
regards to the radical left or even the
alt-right
yeah well i think in terms of i think in
terms
of cain and abel i really do i do think
that jordan peterson
has hit the nail in the right place in
terms of that story and how it relates
to
today in the sense of resentment and i
think that
in the story of cain and abel especially
you see
uh cain who feels like
he should have more than what he has and
it's not just and so it becomes the
basic
you could say that it's pride right
pride is the is the first sin it's the
first sin in
pretty much all the whole biblical story
you know
the devil sin is pride cain's sin his
pride adam and eve sin
is pride as well it's it's the feeling
that
i deserve more than what what i should
have
and it's always relative to someone else
because it's not it it's almost
equivalent to i should have more
but also you shouldn't have that if i
don't have that you shouldn't have that
oh yeah for sure
no i totally agree and i think that
that's
it seems to be i think that that's
that's for sure if you talk to people
who
are far on the left uh far on the left
you could say
you it doesn't take a long time to
scratch
at the fact that what frustrates them
is not so much that they're poor because
most of the time at least
here they're not you know not you know
there's
very few people starving in canada i
mean i'm sure there are but there are
very few
um it's usually that they're annoyed to
think of jeff bezos in his
you know his huge house and that's what
that's what annoys them
um and i think that i mean i'm not
saying that there isn't something to say
for the problem of disparity and
the problem of people of one person
having too much power
i think that that's something which is
important to think about and to talk
about
where where certain individuals have so
much power
that they'd be actually can become a
danger to social cohesion
but but i think that if it's if you look
at it
out of resentment in the sense like you
know why
why would he why why does he why would
he get that
and why why not me you know it's not
fair that kind of thinking
i think that doesn't leave the person in
a in a good situation
um and we see it in the storm kane of
course is where he
ends up killing his brother because
because he
and in the story of cain what's
interesting in that story is that it
doesn't tell you
it doesn't tell you why it's really it's
really fascinating because
later traditions have always tried to
like to try to guess why
why is it that cain sacrifice was not
acceptable to god but in the story
itself it doesn't say
it just says cain's sacrifice was not
acceptable able sacrifice is acceptable
it's like okay you don't even know why
and so but it doesn't matter it's like
that's reality right
another way to see it is this is these
are the cards that have been dealt you
this is it you can't argue with reality
and so are you going to argue with
reality are you going to say
i should have more and and i'm going to
want
more so much and i'm willing to blow the
whole thing up just because i don't have
what i want
you know and and i think that
what you see what you're seeing in the
especially in the
in the radical left is you definitely
see that type of
that type of thing and you see it too
like like you said you do see it now
in the extreme right you're seeing
similar things as well where
there there is a nihilism which is
propping up in the more extreme right
which is you know basically
our culture western culture is is over
so let's just participate in and blowing
it up like let's just
let's just run it into the ground you
know so no one can have it
uh there's a little bit of that going on
and it's very disturbing
to watch so yeah something that
i always struggle with is the radical
left-hand side
there is a there is there is a grain of
truth more than a grain of truth which
is that
we don't all have what we want which
will never all have what we want but
there's some basic needs so in in canada
we all have health care
so let's just forget but let's say in
the states so they don't all have health
care
they don't all have they all are many
people are living paycheck to paycheck
and then they look at someone like jeff
bezos and they say it's not fair that
someone should be living
so insouciantly and free
while i am just struggling yeah
okay so there is something to be said
about not having to struggle
this much for basic necessities then at
the same time there is something to be
said of
well are you trying to be a champion for
the cause of people who are struggling
or
are you just trying to tear down those
who have much more than you now there is
something there is
also something to be said for again
tearing down those who have
disproportionately too much simply
because we don't want power to
accumulate in the hands of the few
and in crony capitalism capitalism
obviously money translates into politics
and we don't want that so it's there's i
see both sides and i'm always struggling
because i see the benevolent side of the
radical left
which is riches which is the benevolent
side of the left in general
yeah and then obviously the benevolent
side of the right comes out as well
which
is well we need hierarchies you can't
just dispense with all hierarchies
what for what do you what is it that you
struggle with you struggle with
so i think that the left the left
because any attempt to criticize the
radical left
they can just say no it's not this claim
of resentment it's
that all that nice bona me gracious
altruistic philanthropic
aspect all those all those elements that
you just listed that's that's actually
our true motivation
yeah and it's difficult well you can
look you can take the psychoanalytical
approach which is something i'm going to
try to do in the documentary which is
well what do your behaviors show forget
about what you say yeah let's see how
you act
so are you killing tens of millions of
people in the in the 1900s
well obviously they didn't but i'm
saying the same philosophy
has and are you clapping when jordan
peterson is debating slavoy
jezek z z and
jordan peterson references bloody
violent revolution and then the rest and
then the radical left
says yeah which happened i don't know if
you saw i saw i saw the one
scene where he says he says hierarchies
are not he says hierarchies are not
all posited on on violence and
dispossessing and everything
and then someone laughs and i thought
his q his answer was so perfect
and he said he said well maybe those
that laugh if that's the way they would
do it
and i thought wow jordan that's one of
those gold moments
there was another time where he just
mentioned what would happen is bloody
violent revolution
and then the uh yeah
yeah he didn't know what to say well
yeah how would you know to say to that
because
i mean i think and those people have
never experienced anything close to
bloody violent revolution
like i was so for this documentary i
started looking at clips
of just just
just the worst some of the worst of what
humans can do to other humans on a large
scale
and and it just it just tears you apart
man
like some of them are not that
visceral because there's black and white
footage with no sound yeah
they're still and then some are like the
what the tamil tigers
what the singles government did to the
tamil tigers and then you see
mothers holding their children and their
children just screaming because their
bombs being
dropped on them ahead and they don't
know if they're gonna and they die and
and it's just fear and fear and fear
breaks your heart and that's what a
violent
revolution is like yeah no i think that
i think especially now you know it's
it's so i think that's what's difficult
is that
you know you can imagine that someone
in the 19th century just coming out of
very difficult like let's say different
very difficult times in russia where
you're present you're barely eating
you don't get to eat any meat all the
aristocrats eat meat you know like that
kind of
life where it's very it's very difficult
and then that you would feel so
desperate that you would be willing to
to risk everything you know just to
topple the whole thing
uh compared to now which is like
i mean who are these people like who
want bloody revolution in our
in our country the top 1 of anybody
who's ever lived right
and i so i don't understand like i don't
i don't totally understand
how that and i also don't understand
this how they define what
rich is because rich to me always seems
to be
defined by them as whoever is richer
than me exactly no
no i agree i agree uh yeah
yeah so what other ancient stories have
you read
yeah that apply to this modern time this
radical life
alt-right crazy world that we live in
um i was thinking about that and
and i don't and i don't i don't totally
see
in terms of we seem to be in a very
unique moment
because one of the things that's
happening right now which is which is
extremely
unique is that we have these two
excesses that are growing up at the same
time
and i think that that's the one thing
that people find very difficult to see
because
they tend to just see the other excess
right
and so for example we we live in a world
where
there's more control and more
calculation of what you're doing than
ever any other time in the history of
the world
right google has everything about you
right you exist virtually in google's
uh on some google drive there they know
everything about you
know everything you've said everything
you've thought pretty much they can call
you from your email you could basically
call you from your email and your
your behavior it's not just your emails
your behavior online what you click here
which
they they have these gigantic algorithms
which calculate
and they know like where you are what
you're interested in you know there are
crazy stories of people who
who uh you know like a with a girl who
is looking online for certain things not
related to pregnancy but they've
calculated that
if you look online for certain things
even if it's not directly related to
pregnancy
it probably means you're pregnant and so
they'll show you ads for pregnancy stuff
right
so there's this massive uh data
control over what we are just in terms
of laws like
the modern state no i can't i can't
build something in my yard i need to get
permission from my
town to build anything i want like i
can't right now we're in the process in
quebec where
the government wants to we're
homeschooling our kids and the
government wants to
to force us to take standardized tests
and they think that's normal like i
think it's normal that the government
decides
what your kids are going to learn we we
think that's strong we think that the
government has that
possibility so we have the most but we
also have this weird
carnivalesque crazy world of passions
where
you know pornography is rampant where
people are are
people are dying from from uh from
opioids and so
there's also this other weird world
that's completely
chaotic and upside down so we have these
two things that are kind of growing up
at the same time
and so it's almost like this is a very
unique moment
in history where the capacity for
absolute control and the capacity for
absolute breakdown
seem to be looking at each other and
somehow feeding into each other
so it's very weird i don't know if
there's a certain
are there any biblical stories
my brother would probably be better at
finding at finding a story that shows
as much the two extremes at the same
time um
i mean it's possible that maybe the
closest thing we have
would be the collapse of of the roman
empire
maybe like like the collapse of of uh
the the the first collapse let's say
third
third century collapse where it's as if
there was this huge gigantic
bureaucratic state crazy
but then this these decadent elites that
were
all they cared about were their orgies
and then it's like it just couldn't
couldn't hold and so it's like it
collapsed into civil war
so it seems like maybe that's the
closest thing that we have to
understanding kind of where
we like the symptoms of our society
seems to be seem to be close to
let's say that uh that first fall there
in the in the
second one reason i'm asking is because
there's so much wisdom in these old
stories
and if we want to if we want to engineer
a solution to
our current times it's always good to
look back and see well what did they do
then
yeah you know i don't think there's a
solution to our current time
i i i wish i i wish and a lot of people
you know
and i think that that's one of the
reasons why i kind of took on
jordan's way of seeing things in terms
of the solution
a lot of people have criticized me just
for for kind of coming too close to
jordan as a christian and
a lot of people have criticized jordan
for his
his individualism you could say and i've
been thinking about it a lot recently
and i think that
i think that jordan's solution is the
only one right now
not individualism in the sense of not
the iron right
exactly not the around kind of selfish
individual but
the notion that the in a world that is
so
extreme right now and the systems are so
big
you know the only thing you can do is
is become a saint right as much as
possible
is to become a just in the world to be
to be an
anchor for for people around you
and so and that means changing yourself
that means
uh and i think it is in line with the
deepest christian
teaching which is you know take take the
the beam out of your own eye before
before removing the straw out of your
brother's eye and i and there's also
several citations of saints for example
saint seraphim of sorrow who said
acquire the spirit of peace and
thousands around you will be saved
and so this notion of becoming something
rather than trying to
to to immediately want to to find these
gigantic
solutions to the problem because i don't
i think i think
i think we're headed for trouble and i
think that the only
the only hope is that there will be
enough
bastions of civility and and justice
and and truth to to
carry us through right to carry us
through the the the
the chaos because to be honest i don't
see
i don't see us fixing this these massive
problems they're too big they're so big
it's like it's like the ai thing you
know you have all these people saying
be careful about ai be careful about ai
but no one's gonna stop it's just this
this machine is turning and turning and
speeding up and we're heading towards it
everybody knows we're heading towards it
everybody's afraid everybody knows how
dangerous it could be but no one can
stop it
you know elon musk can't stop it no one
can stop it it's going to happen
and so i don't know you know
i don't i sorry to be a pessimist
so where do you see it going you just
see it remaining and then we strengthen
ourselves as individuals becoming a
a person that someone can rely on an
anchor
i i think that no i think that it has to
i do think that it has to build
ground up that for sure and i think
that we need we need to rediscover
our center our heart right we need to
rediscover that and then we also need
to participate in actual communities and
that's one of the reasons why
i i tell people that oh wait you mean to
say to say that it
you don't see it going away the problem
of the extreme writing extreme left
with some large-scale solution you see
it as a problem that will be solved from
a
bottom-up approaches you they can only
be i think it can only be solved by a
bottom-up approach
it's the same problem with with the
ecological problem
the ecological problem is too big
because it's based in people's desires
the the problem the ecological problem
is based on
our desire to accumulate and to
to have to have to supplement our
existence
to that extent so the problem is so
profound
that no matter what no matter what
recycling you set up it's not going to
go away
it's not going to go away the only thing
that can make it go away is for
transformed people
and transformed communities but we don't
like communities we they don't exist
anymore we don't have
at least some some do but it's it's very
difficult we are this is why john
vervacky dates the
current meaning crisis he's he says well
he might say
because he's complicated man he might
say that the extreme radical left
extreme
extreme alt-right are symptoms of a
deeper meaning crisis and this meaning
crisis dates back to the year
1200 yeah for sure i totally agree i
when he said 12th century i was like
john you got it that's where it started
that's where all
the the west started to to vacillate
let's say between extremes
and uh and so it's it's a it's a
cyclical thing
it's a story that's too big for us it's
too big for
individuals to think that they're going
to change it but there are ways to exist
in those times of breakdown
like there are ways to exist which
alleviate
let's say or make you not be a an actor
in
the breakdown and henceforth not be an
actor in your own breakdown
not not fall and and and live a life
a dissolute life of of the passions and
be completely taken up by your desires
and then wake up on your deathbed and
it's like okay i have a big house and a
big car
but i'm divorced and my kids hate me and
it's like that's okay
congratulations you know what did you
accomplish
and so one of the reasons why i've
insisted a lot of people
sometimes they wonder why i i insist on
it so much is one of the reasons why i
keep saying that at least in the west
we need we need to remember the
christian story like we need to remember
the fact what it is that made us
something
yeah remember also means understanding
yeah and part i think
it it means to a certain extent
participate in two and so that's why
it's a vervakian idea yeah but i think
we
we don't fall in the same place because
so john's way of
of participation is very individualistic
and so he says i'm a practitioner i
practice this i practice that you know i
i practice these different mystical uh
practices
and it's like for him it's a way out of
the meaning crisis
but it has to it has to come together
too
we have to remember that even in
buddhist in in buddhist teaching
that you know there's a lack of
community in john's approach i think so
i think so and i think the lack of
community
is we don't we don't totally decide what
story we're part of
i keep telling people that people it's
difficult for people to fully understand
it
my the way that i i view how things are
going on is i think
what we're seeing is playing out of in
the west you know we're seeing a playing
out of the christian story
the massive christian story and part of
that story
is a breakdown it's there in the story
you know that's why
yeah you're the only person that i've
seen articulate our current crisis
in this manner that christianity itself
might have to die in order for it to
come back and be reborn
but i think it's it's there in the story
like it's there it's there it's
interesting because you're applying
the narrative to the narrative yeah
that's how symbolism works
so symbolism is a is a you know it's a
embedded structures within themselves
right it's a uh
that the archetype is so true that it
applies to the archetype
well that it's a it's like a
yes exactly it that's that's also that's
what religious stories do in general
like they
they're they they understand how
they understand a form of
self-consciousness they have a form of
self-consciousness where
they they try to look at themselves as
well there's a
weird circularity that's part of the of
the symbolic structure i find that i
find that
fascinating i need to think about that
some more because it's an interesting
idea i haven't heard someone else
express it at least not articulate in
the in the direct manner that you have
yeah so how did you start to come to
view stories
in this symbolic fashion so you're
saying you're 22 or you just graduated
from college and your teacher was
telling you you don't belong here yeah
you're a traditionalist the questions
you're asking are
are not ones that you'll find the answer
to not in college
yeah well so what what what basically
happened is i
i tried to make contemporary art for a
little while i had a studio with some
friends and you know i was kind of
working towards something and then just
for freelance just for some money well
i hope like a real artist like going to
a gallery and do
do do the real artist thing you know i
made these giant you know kind of
really ego ego driven giant giant uh
works of art you know my whole life is
just one big giant ego-driven work of
art
so anyway so that's what i had and then
i i
uh i got married and marriage really
kind of
slammed me against myself like i saw all
my own
flaws flowers insecurities and passions
and and uh
unreasonableness and all that just kind
of came flying back can you explain how
that happens
because i recently got married and so i
want to know i want to know what's the
story from
it depends on people some people
some people get married and then it's
wonderful for a little while and then it
then then the mirror starts to
show um for me it was the opposite like
we got married like a week after we got
married all of a sudden
it was like could you see both of us
could just see
so our first year marriage was hell like
it was it was the opposite of most
people oh yeah it was
absolute hell like we once we got
through the first year of marriage
we were like huh you can never get worse
than that so
it's pretty good let's keep going and so
so i mean it depends on people that's
how it was for us
did you live together beforehand no no
um and so so it was like this just
seeing this mirror and so it led me to a
lot of questioning and
and uh and also just kind of spiritual
crisis in general i was also becoming
very disillusioned with
the world the kind of evangelical world
that i was in in college i'd read a lot
of
of authors a lot of philosophers and
i just felt like the church where i was
going wasn't just wasn't answering the
questions what kind of church was it
this is kind of a baptist
baptist evangelical baptist church kind
of american
style church there uh not liturgical you
know just very
kind of looks like a business meeting
can you explain what you mean when you
say liturgical do you mean
to say what it studies the bible no
liturgical means
that it's that it has a service which is
which is a pattern right it's it's based
on it's not just a
so like let's say a evangelical church
today
they'll get together they'll sing songs
and uh they'll have a sermon
but they'll say things like we could do
it we could do whatever like we you know
there's no
it doesn't matter what you do there's no
structure or you mean no structures for
your life or no structure for the
structure for the meetings right
instruction for the church
and so liturgical means that there's an
order of service and so there's
we we do things in a certain order like
the jehovah's witnesses i don't know if
you're familiar with them
yeah well they're not surgical okay
they're more like more like the even
evangelical baptists
yeah so liturgical is like anglican
catholics orthodox
they're liturgical so they sing they
they they have a
the building the the the architecture of
the building
is meaningful the order of the service
is meaningful the way the
the priest is dressed is meaningful
everything is is done in a manner which
is meaningful
and which is uh which which manifests
what you're trying to do right
so it's not just it's not just arbitrary
so so anyway so i wasn't so i was going
to a kind of evangelical church
and um i felt like it was just lacking
in
in profundity lacking and meeting and
and also
you know i was reading philosophers and
then i started reading
authors from other traditions buddhist
authors sufi authors
and i discovered mystical the mystical
way you could say the mis-mystical
thinking and uh transformational
thinking
you could call it and uh i was really
impressed
by it and then i thought whoa i would
say why is it that christians don't have
that like why is it that christians
don't have the mystical
mystical transformations and mystical
vision of
how the world works and and all of that
and and it was only because
it did it just i didn't know about it
and then i that's when i discovered
the early church fathers and traditional
christianity
and then iconography so can you define
what iconography is
so iconography would be let's say a way
of practicing art which
is traditional in the sense that it has
certain
types certain typology it has a set of
rules
um kind of like if you write a sonata
right you have certain rules
and then you you write within those
rules so
iconography is the visual practice of
the ancient church
which was developed let's say if you
went into a church in the year 1000 or
1100
anywhere in the world you would have
seen pretty much the same thing
and that was done without a top-down a
you know imposition of what was going to
be there but it was
just this kind of bubbling was like the
brand style guide for the church
the what you know my brand styles okay
so when you design a website or
or you have a company like use these
fonts use these colors make sure that
when you place the logo you place it
this much of a distance between the the
borders well i don't think no i don't
think that's the way to see it the way
to see it is to see it
more like a
a vision a view of the world
as full of meaning and full of pattern
and so the story of the world and the
story of our lives is a pattern
it's not arbitrary it's not random and
so
that pattern then can be found let's say
in scripture
can be found and then it it transposes
itself into
the way that we worship let's say so the
structure of how we worship
in a church in a traditional church is
patterned
based on the same patterns as that you
find in the in the bible
so there's a center right there's the
the altar
and then that's the most holy place and
then you can imagine a series of layers
as you move out
from that holy place remember when i
told you a little bit about this idea of
adding layers well you can see that also
in the terms of sacred space where
you have profane space which is outside
the church
and as you move in to the church then
you
you you move towards this sacred center
which is that which defines the space
itself and which defines the community
which defines everything so that
structure let's say the architecture of
a church
then in iconography you have those same
types of structures
so you have to know the the types
it's like you have to understand that
the reason why christ is represented in
a certain way
is not arbitrary it's there to show you
what
who christ is and so there's a certain
manner in which you represent
a figure to show you who what they are
and what their place is in this bigger
pattern did they do this consciously
like they knew that
they were not copying or imitating but
that if this
specific representation of christ was
being repeated in
other parts of the world did they know
that consciously that here's
the proper representation of christ or
here's what it's saying we're
we're at the center because this is
what's most holy and then here's what's
profane
in the way that you're articulating it
yeah but i think as a mix i think it's a
mix of intuition
and participation in the life of a
community where we agree on
certain things and we participate in the
story and so for example like if you
would ask me
would it be conscious to put christ in a
central space
and you would say well yeah but at the
same time what else are you gonna put
there
because that's the center that's the
incarnation that's the point where
heaven and earth meet
that's the that's the the focus of
of the the origin of christianity the
focus of christianity so it's like
where else would you put him there's
another reason for the cross something
i've been thinking about another
reason for the cross to be symbolized
like this is because
this represents the spiritual and this
represents the profane the mundane
earthly
and the proper places to be at both but
then
the other reason why the earthly is a
little bit higher is because it's more
important to be slightly more spiritual
than you are
earthly i mean yeah i've never thought
about the second part that you said for
sure the cross the cross
is meant to represent the union of
heaven and earth that's for sure
um and i think that a lot of people
resist that because they say no that's
the shape of a
actual cross right that's how it crosses
multiple meanings
but it's like that's the thing is that
symbolism is not uh
symbolism is the coalescence of things
it's not a it's not a
just because it's a it's that's how
crosses were made doesn't mean
that it doesn't also mean that
especially in this context that doesn't
come to mean that
and there's also a preponderance of
things that are associated with christ
and why would we choose the cross well
there's
obviously obvious reasons why we would
choose the cross
but the cross as a symbol means
it has multiple meanings yeah and it
does it definitely is a center that's
for sure
and and if you look at the early church
fathers they'll say things like
you know the cross is everywhere you
know look at the
boat amassed you know a mast of a boat
with the sail
that's a cross and they'll they'll point
to crosses which exists almost naturally
in the world and say this is the you
know the image of the cross has been
shown
forever you know we people need to just
recognize what it's talking about like
what is this center what what's at the
center actually like what
does unite heaven and earth you know
that's the question and that's
that's and of course christians answer
with the incarnation that's the that's
the answer but iconography
is basically understanding the rules
and the language of christian art why
it's
why it resembles what it does
and then it's almost like an algebra and
so you know that the terms then you can
if you need to improvise an image you
can but to improvising that image needs
to be done within
the general frames and tenants
that the iconography offers you you know
so it's a it's a truly
traditional truly traditional art in
that sense
okay so you started studying iconography
because you were your eyes were opened
yeah because you started studying
buddhism and you realized they have an
interesting way of
seeing the world yeah well it was it was
a lot it wasn't buddhism it was
a little bit of buddhism a lot of uh
sufi
authors um i read some some early modern
uh kind of sufi converts and uh
oh sufi is a mystical islam yeah it's a
it's a branch of
of islam which is which is far more
mystical analogical
and uh it's closer some people argue
with me if i say this but
it's closer to christianity in in some
respects because
because of its emphasis on love and
because it's emphasis on
on transformational on the
transformation of the person all of that
to get you into more hot water yeah than
you already are do you fundamentally see
islam as a religion of peace
the i think that we need to see okay we
need to see islam
for what for what islam actually says
and so religion islam is a religion
there are two spheres in islam
there's the there's the the sphere of
peace
and there's the sphere of war and islam
is the religion of peace
in the sense that within islam is peace
and that's how that's how it's viewed in
the muslim world
that's how it's been presented and so
you have the outside world which is the
the space of war
and you have the inside of islam which
is the space of peace
and one of the goals of islam is to
to to bring peace to bring the space of
peace to the world
but that's why by becoming by becoming
muslim
or for by submitting to islam somehow
by becoming a demi or you know by paying
the the tribute
and that's that i mean a lot of muslims
don't think that today a lot of i mean
i would say that most muslims in the
west don't don't
don't have that approach to islam
anymore
um but traditionally that's what islam
that's why islam is an expansive has was
from the beginning an expansive
religion you know judaism is not
expansive judaism
is is wants to recover the holy land
like they just want their
they want to get their their their place
without it does that does cause trouble
obviously we see that it's caused
trouble
since they're back there it's a
difficult situation
but uh and christianity it's
it's kind of not clear you know because
the roman empire converted to
christianity
so then the roman empire became
christian
and so it's complicated to think it's
not so much that then christians went
out and
at least in the first you know thousand
years went out and invaded other
places although it probably happened uh
you know you get stories in the west
you get stories of of of uh you know
charlemagne converting by the sword and
you get those stories as well
but they're always kind of iffy but
islam was like
islam exploded became huge if you look
at a an
image of the map at the year 1000 you
know it's it's
it's immense and so yeah so i mean i
don't know
i think that most muslims today are not
especially people who come here it
depends from where they come from and
what intentions they have you know in
quebec here a lot of the muslims who
come here come from northern africa and
they you know they want to work they
want to have a good life they want to
have a good family they want to
to be left alone and do their thing and
uh yeah so
okay so let's get back to you were
studying studying iconography
and that allowed you to see the world
and see stories through a particular
lens
yeah i was watching you give an
interview i mean i was watching you have
a conversation about the spider-verse
with someone yeah
and that person then made a comment
about some other some other aspect of
the spider verse and then you said oh
and what that could mean is this this
this and this
and then the guy said oh i didn't see
that before and then you said oh i
didn't see it before until you mentioned
it
and that made me realize you that's not
something you thought about because
for a tr for a regular person a regular
person who's even watching this
they would have to sit and think okay
what could the spider verse mean to
here's what i know okay okay okay this
fits in here this fits in here this
doesn't work okay okay
and then it would take them maybe 20
minutes to come up with something that
you came up with in a
in the span of a sentence or two which
means you actually
see the world or you've thought about it
for so long that it's just second nature
to you
and i want to know how did that develop
and how do you see the world
so do you see people walking down the
street
differently than you used to no i mean
that seriously because even people who
study physiology
they can tell people's ailments
just by watching them walk even if they
look like they're normal oh you you
slightly tilt in this direction
it's almost like sherlock holmes and so
you see people moving
towards the subway and then you think
okay that's a that's a place of
communion where people don't interact
that's almost like what we had in the
12th century when this happened and this
happened
so i want to know do you see the world
like that no i see
i and how did you start to see the world
the way you see the world
um i mean i think i i see the world
through patterns that's for sure
uh okay now when you say patterns i'm
gonna get specific here so when you say
patterns
you mean repetitions parts
of life that repeat or parts of life
that are abstracted so for example
there's a pattern of talking where i
talk you talk i talk utah now that's a
pattern okay it's repeating
or another pattern is is you abstract
out from a certain set
so there's a pattern of what it means to
be human right so
it's i would say
okay so the pattern you could say the
pattern starts
with how things exist right
and when i say how things exist what i
mean is how they exist
phenomenologically not in terms of
science
because that's what confuses me in terms
of experience in terms of experience
how we experience things existing and
that's really the basis of how things
exist
no matter what we say like we we we try
to push
beyond the phenomenological but we
always see it through the lens so the
scientist even though he has all these
scientific categories
he's still in a consciousness and
looking at the world through that
consciousness
and or she he or she he or she yeah just
just
don't send any letters um
and so the the way that something for
exa i'll give you a perfect example so
the way that something exists
you need for something to exist to have
it have an identity
right and then have a you could say
a variety say it that way you need to
have an identity and
a variety or a oneness and a
multipleness to it can you give me an
example
well so if i have a so i i have
a cup so this has an identity and it's
it's let's say it's identity is
is the cup that's part of it there has
it has other identities but let's use
that one for
for start so it has an identity it's a
cup but then it also
it also is not just
there is no such thing as a cup it's
actually non-binary and it's offended
that you defined it in terms of
well there's no such thing as there's no
pure cup
right not in the world right so a cup
has to have
and has to have a particular
particularity to it
right and the particularity to it is its
variety it's a multiplicity
and then in order for it to have
particularity then it has to
embody other identities so it has a
color it has
you know it has to have a color right
but it there's no color in the cup
cup doesn't have color but it has to
have color so there's there's the
concept of cupness
which doesn't actually exist in the
world in space and time
but it's a concept nonetheless something
that makes something
essence it's a concept i try not to get
too tight up in
because people say okay you're being
platonic just trying to to see
how things come to to exist and so so
there's an aspect of it which is one
there's an aspect of it which is
multiple and everything
always has to to to have that for
anything to exist
it has to be one and multiple at the
same time because it also has to be
constitutive
constituted by parts okay so you're
saying the elements of this that are not
a cup are
but also for even for it to be a cup it
also needs to be
constituted with parts so it has one
oneness and it also has parts which are
multiple and the
cuppness of the cup holds the cup
together right so let's just say that
just have one and one in many
okay okay so if you have one in many
just that
yeah you already have a basic pattern
and then you could look at the world
through one in many
and and you can notice when things move
towards one
or when they move towards many or how
they move towards one
how they move towards many okay so then
let's do that in space
you a good way to represent it in space
best way to represent in space
center periphery so you have a wheel
let's say
you have a center the center is that
which around everything else turns
and then as you move out from the center
you get more
quantity you could say as you move
towards the center you get more quality
and so that's a basic pattern so you can
look at a person like that
that's extremely interesting you could
also look at the political sphere like
that
would you say the radical left is on the
periphery and then the
alt-right is in the extreme center
um i struggle with this alt-right thing
but let's talk about the rat because
let's talk about the radical
the radical left okay so the let's say
the left so you
let's say right hand left hand we can
use that okay so right the right hand
traditionally really this is
i'm not making this up the right hand
traditionally is the tendency to move
towards the center
and the left hand is the tendency to
move away from the center and so
for example christ says when he's
judging the world he says
to the sheep he says come into my
kingdom
and to the goats he says depart from me
i never knew you
okay so moving towards the center moving
away from the center
there's a rabbinical teaching that says
exactly that which is you know bring
things closer to you with your right
hand
move them away from you with your left
hand right so you now you can think of
it as a person
traditionally in any traditional culture
almost every single traditional culture
you eat with what hand you're right you
wash with what hand you're right
you watch with your left hand oh because
you're moving because you don't want to
eat with what you wash with you go to
the bathroom use your left hand
you eat with your right hand right so
you bring towards you with your right
hand
you move away from you with your left
hand right so you understand
that that's just a basic pattern of
being like a person
has a tendency towards unity and a
tendency towards
outside towards inside towards outside
that's
that's a pattern that's a basic pattern
of reality then you can
you can apply that to a society society
has a basic identity
and it has ways in which you move
towards that identity and then it has
a way in which you move away from that
identity but you could moving away or
closer
is not moral right because some things
you need to move you need to to
move away from you and there's some
things also that move away for you for
from you for a good reason right in the
sense that
you could be extending yourself out into
the world as well right
and so and so it's not it's not the
patterns are not moral there's no
in in the pattern there's nothing good
or bad they can become good or bad
depending on how they're used
for what reason they're used but the
pattern itself is
it just then you can look at the world
and you can what i see when i look at
the world is
that's what i see i see how the pattern
is manifested
in different instances now this
detaching of
moral judgments from how close you are
to the center or how far you are
from the center is that a buddhist
concept or
does that fall in line with christianity
because i know christianity has an
has a and a
an emphasis an emphasis on putting moral
judgments on
almost every aspect and buddhism is the
opposite as far as i know
i could be wrong so does that does that
okay so you said
look there's the center there's the
moving away from the center and you can
move toward you can move towards center
you can move away from the center it's
not
in and of itself a i mean it's not in
and of itself moralistic to do
one of no one of the others they both
have danger and they both have
opportunity
the buddhists won't necessarily frame it
in the same terms but
he they will they'll say the passions
they'll say you have these passions
on the edges say on in yourself and
those passions are pulling you
are fragmenting you they're pulling you
apart and in the christian
the christian way of describing the
passions in the same way especially in
the orthodox tradition
do you have these passions these desires
and these desires pull you away from
your heart let's say and uh and you need
to go back to your heart you need to
to to to uh to let's say
so that's a return to the center it
returns and you return to the center
okay
um and do they have in christianity a
pushing away from the center
well it depends like i said for example
i'll give you an example of a pushing
away from the center which is
which is positive the pentecost
pentecost is when
the disciples are in the high place and
then
all of a sudden the the fire of the holy
spirit comes down upon them and then
they start to speak and then
everybody can hear them speak in their
own language
and so as they're speaking then
everybody else is hearing them
speak in the language that they
understand so that's that's a fire
right that's fire that's the left hand
that's moving away from the center
and so the message is is being dispersed
out
into the into the periphery because
those who are outside
hear the language hear the message in
their own language
and so that's a left-hand movement it's
it's it's a moving out
um and so so so like i said it's not
necessarily good
good or bad uh and then then there's
also
there's a bad left hand right this idea
of giving in to your
fire giving in to your desires giving in
to your passions is this
this being pulled away you know from
yourself
and and that would be represented as a
kind of left hand
uh movement you could say but there are
also right hand sins
so saint max was the confessor for
example talks about left hand
and right hand sins and he says the
left-hand sins are you know uh
gluttony prostitution all the sins of
the passions like you let yourself go to
to uh to to those types of desires
and the sins of the right hand are pride
self-sufficience right
so now you can see where the the the
moving into the center
can become negative in the sense of of
pride the sense of thinking that you're
that you don't need anything the sense
of thinking that you're self-sufficient
and so like i said those patterns are
not they're not they're not negative or
positive
um it's just in their balance well it
just it just depends on
on in the situation the situation it
just depends on what is
trying to be accomplished so entering
into the center in the sense of
removing yourself from your passions and
going into the center in order to
to look up and see what's above you okay
so simply just a matter of
appropriateness to the situation right
sometimes you need to be far
sometimes you need to be close yes okay
it just depends also
you could say a good way not necessarily
i was wrong when i said balance because
that would imply that there's a proper
place to occupy in almost every
situation whereas it's actually
different
sometimes you just need to be completely
right-handed sometimes you need to be
left-handed sometimes you need to be a
mixture of both so a good
a good way to so in terms of center and
and periphery for example the good way
to understand it is
uh like it's called memory
so if you're moving away from the center
if you remember the center
then it doesn't matter how far you go
right so it's like you
um if you remember yourself
if you remember god if you no matter how
you say it doesn't you can go
very far and you won't fall you could
say you won't be
taken in by whatever is pulling you
out you know um does that make sense
yeah yeah okay so now you see the world
like this you see the world you said you
started to see the world
primarily through the center periphery
dichotomy
that's one that's a that's an easy way
to understand it okay at some point it
transcends those
those categories but that's the the best
way to explain it i think is
is is using hierarchy uh like a like a
mountain or pyramid or
and periphery those are the best way to
explain it so now when you watch
something like a movie
how do you see the movie yeah what are
you looking for
are you looking for anything does it
just unconsciously hit you and you
realize
it hits me it doesn't i don't uh i
usually just watch a movie
and then i'll take a little bit of time
and uh and then i have insight can you
give me an example of your thought
process
from a a very recent movie so that it's
fresh in your mind so some movie that
you saw recently
that you went in thinking okay i'm just
gonna watch this movie
and then what thoughts occurred to you
and then what thoughts occurred to you
afterwards
okay uh so okay what did i i just went
to see shazam with my kids i went to see
that movie
uh and uh
so the movie shazam is about a young man
a young boy who becomes a superhero an
adult superhero right
and uh and he and
the movie is for example one of the
images that keeps appearing in the movie
is an image of the carnival
and the carnival keeps coming back and
so for example like if if an image like
that keeps coming back
especially the carnival then you say
okay i need to pay attention
to this because there's something going
on here
and uh and so so a carnival for example
is
is this edge the carnival is the edge of
the world
the best way to understand it it's
everything is upside down right
everything's spinning
everything in a carnival is spinning all
the time you know the ferris wheel all
the rides everything's spinning
uh and and uh and everything is
is uh is is a garish
you know all the colors are garish
everything is there to to
titillate you in that's in that way so
it's all bad
food it's all it's all spinning it's all
uh laughing and pleasure in in the very
basis sense of
of having fun you know in clowns and uh
and impossible um impossible uh
precision games where you try to hit the
center but you're not gonna hit the
center
no one hits the center right no one all
those precision games where you win
these big things like
it's they're they're very difficult so
it's like okay so this is what's going
on
and so then you think okay so the story
is about in this should i don't want to
give
all these spoilers but the story in uh
in shazam is about
dealing with the seven deadly sins and
so it's like okay so here's all of this
going on at the same time
so these seven deadly sins kind of come
out and possess
this one man you know and then
they they start to kind of attack the
world and do all this stuff
so okay so the seven deadly sins at a
carnival
it all kind of makes sense it's like it
all kind of fits together
it's not trying to say anything right
it's not it's not like there's a message
but the pattern is right and so when the
pattern is right
where the seven deadly sins appear at a
carnival
it's like it fits and then you when you
look at when you're watching it
you you have a kind of satisfaction
which is the satisfaction of the world
being right even if it's talking about
the upside down world right it's talking
about these monstrous seven deadly
passions that are coming to
to suck to suck up the world but it's
having it in a carnival
which is an upside-down world already
and so all of this is going on and so
it's like even though it's showing you
the
the extremes it's fits because it's
everything's in the right place
and so when when sometimes what can
happen is if
you could have it you could have a place
where it just is wrong where it just
doesn't
doesn't work where it's and that and
that's because
you're interpreting it incorrectly or
you feel like it's being forced on the
part of the filmmaking worst
exactly it's just being forced so
there's a desire
to to give a message and so they'll push
something
in which will which will force it but
the best way to force it is to
because it's difficult to get away from
these patterns because they're the
patterns of reality
all you can do is you can you can make
them upside down
you can uh twist them right so you can't
totally get rid of them
and so i think that a lot of the the
modern kind of propaganda
that's what they do is they they twist
them in a way they kind of just
toss them to it make them like the idea
of yes we need we can't avoid the
masculine feminine
archetypes so what we'll do is we'll put
a woman in the place of the masculine
figure and we'll put a man in the place
of the feminine figure and demean the
man
sorry and i mean the man denigrate him
so it's like so we're still using the
same pattern
but we're just doing it in a way that's
kind of flipping it upside down or
playing with it in a way that is is is
confusing or is
meant to create uh disjunction you could
say
how does one know when they're reading
reading too much
into a piece of art something that
peterson's been criticized with for
on a minor basis like when you when he's
looking at pinocchio how do you know
you're not reading too much into it so
how does one
prevent themselves from reading too much
in is there such a thing as reading too
much into art
of course yeah for sure and i think that
the way that for example what i do is i
just point at the pattern
so it's not i'm not i'm not actually
interpreting the movie usually when i
interpret a movie i'm not interpreting
in the sense of saying
this aspect of the movie represents
uh you know i don't know represents uh
hitler and this aspect this this this
character in the movie represents
stalin and here this is what it's like i
never i would never
make an interpretation of a movie like
that you know i'll say
he look at the pattern right here that
here are the
here are the uh the terms of the pattern
right you have someone on the inside you
have someone on the outside
how are they interacting
so we're talking about how does one know
when they're reading too much into art
and you were saying
well i'm not gonna substitute different
elements of the film and say this
represents
the struggle of man and this represents
the church and this represents hitler
yeah
usually a movie will give you its
pattern it'll it'll
it'll lay it a little because it has to
right the movie has a pattern
in order for you to even recognize it as
a story especially movies that
especially moves that are trying to make
money who is that movies like little art
type movies where
the person doesn't care whether or not
anybody watches it usually those
you're hopeless like you're hopeless in
terms of pattern but movies that are
actually trying to attract a lot of
people
they have to they no matter even if the
person isn't conscious about it
in order to attract a mass amount of
attention they
they have to embody certain satisfying
patterns
that human beings have within them it's
necessary for because people won't go
see them
or the cynic would say it's just
marketed well that's not true
because we know movies that have been
massively marketed which have failed
right and so you know maybe they'll have
that first bump but then
it'll all go away whereas whereas if you
really want to attract a lot of
attention you need to
to have that pattern and so the idea is
the movie will usually tell you like
what's going on and so you just need to
let the movie tell you
what's what's happening and trying to i
always try not to go outside of the
movie
like at least the least that i can like
try not to reference anything outside
the actual story that's going on
and to just say well this character says
this this is what he does
this is this is how this is his struggle
he's telling you what's a struggle he's
going to tell you this is this is this
is his problem
he's going to tell you what the solution
is then all i'm going to try to do is
show you
how that is a pattern and how it would
how it's a pattern and then once i've
done that
then i can say okay now this pattern see
this pattern
this is the same as this other pattern
this other pattern
this other pattern like see how uh
you know like for example the pattern of
resurrection you know
and that pattern is there everywhere
someone dies or almost dies and then
gets back up at the end
it's like you see it in so many movies
you know that's a
it's just there it's just there in the
story you know i can show you that it's
there
and then once i've shown you that it's
there then maybe we can start to talk
about
what it means but it's no longer now
about just that one movie
right it's about that pattern which is
there in several other stories
and now we can talk about what it what
it's
what it's referring to in terms of
existential reality
um and so to me if you stay within those
those frames you have less of a danger
of
of kind of going overboard one of the
things that happens and it's happened to
me
is that sometimes you'll see a pattern
and
you won't see a counter pattern you
won't see you'll see
you'll you'll want to see one aspect of
the pattern
too much then you won't see something
else that's going on so that's
that's totally possible can you explain
what you mean you mean to say that you
as the person who's interpreting the
piece of art wants to see a certain
pattern and so
it blinds you to a counter pattern yeah
for sure
because that means that in other words
you're selectively choosing well that's
what a pattern is right a pattern is
is is is the selectivity
because just like a movie just like any
other reality
has an indefinite amount of details
right it's a you could talk about
the way the leads are moving in the
story but you're not going to talk about
that because that's not what interests
you
and so you'll focus on the characters
for example you could say
you know you could interpret you could
you could you could ask
if you were just a kind of nihilist you
could ask why are you focusing on the
characters
when you're watching a movie why aren't
you focusing on uh
on the top right pixel exactly or the
yeah the the way the wind is blowing
well some people who have autism do that
they don't actually look at characters
on
yeah they don't look at characters in
the eye you can watch them you can track
their their
eye fixations and they don't look so
right now i'm looking at you in the eye
and they don't watch the characters they
look at the light bulbs they watch how
this
swing is swinging yeah and capacity to
kind of bring things together
um and so that's so it's inevitable that
you will
do like you will selectively choose
but sometimes there there can be
other patterns that are there that you
that you might ignore that you might
you might marginalize you could say and
that's in a way it's kind of inevitable
but hopefully you tried to not to not do
it too much and also to be able
to see both and to see both sides the i
think the best interpretations that i've
done for movies have been the ones where
i'm able to show the two sides let's say
to almost sometimes imagine as if you
could see the movie from
from different aspects so let's say
you're an artist and you want to create
something that's not propagandistic that
doesn't
try to you don't try to instill your own
values into the art
because otherwise you would call that
jung carl jung would call that
propagandistic versus
exploration art or he called it the
difference between introverted art and
extroverted art so introverted art is
the art where you're trying to you have
your own intentions
and you're just using the art as a tool
to
let the world know what you think
politically it's usually political but
yeah
it could be whatever it could be you're
the main character in the film because
you're filming it yourself and you want
people to feel sorry for you
it could be whatever or you want you had
a bad experience with the father and now
you want to make sure that people when
they look at their fathers they have a
bad experience with their father like
they
look at fathers negatively yeah okay
then he said there's extroverted art
where it just comes through you you're a
conduit
for which these ideas flow from and you
don't even know what you're doing when
you do it
and until it comes together as a
cohesive home maybe you can look back
but maybe you can't even look back
and as much as you try to explain it you
realize it's deeper than my explanation
you come back one year from now
and there's more there's more to it more
to it more to it religious but by
religion is like the bible's or the
bible is like that
so you would call that extroverted art
what advice would you have
for artists who would like to
not fall prey to introverted art they
want to
be they want to do art that will last
they will stand the test of time and not
right which i think it's difficult it's
difficult
for me to answer that question because
i'm not making the kind of extroverted
art that
that young is talking about the the i
let's say the liturgical art that i make
is is a
is a desire to participate in a
community in a communal language
and so it's very different it's neither
me trying to
impose my vision of the world on others
nor is it
this kind of surrealist type of
exploratory art where you
like you said like you just kind of let
yourself go and you don't know what
you're doing it kind of
almost uh you know like uh
like a medium or something um it's it's
completely different it's
actually trying to participate in a
common language
and so so like i said i that that to me
i've chosen that as being the most
because the problem with
well i don't see anything wrong with
that because let's say you're a poet
you're using the language
of english or whatever language you're
using so you're using the the language
of iconography and then you're
constructing within that yeah so i don't
see that as necessarily being opposed to
introverted art or extraverted i mean i
don't see that as you trying to will
a certain point of view i just see it
it's you using a language well maybe
it's because maybe it's because of
my idea of the the of how i understand
what you're talking about when you talk
about the extroverted art which is
this kind of um
you know this kind of letting it flow
right almost like a surrealist like
other they make uh
um how they would they would automatic
writing all that kind of stuff
i think you can just think of it as the
absence of an intentional message
right well yeah no i i i think that in
terms of
of uh of reducing a message i would say
i think that understanding the
complexity of traditional stories
is probably a way to to help that in the
sense that
to try to always see the the old
testament characters are some of the
best for that
right you can read the bible the old
testament characters
and you can read them as
the hero and almost every single
character you can read them as a villain
almost every single one
you can see how they actually
there's a shady aspect to what they're
doing okay you can do that about
you can dab up every single character in
the old testament it's really
fascinating
by the way to do that and i think that
being aware of that
is is probably helpful
is to understand that
there are two sides to to the symbolism
all the time there's always
there's always two sides and that's
something that's wrong or missing in
modern movies like
like you said the one with the the
reversal of little mermaid
what was it called dierra geltorum or
the del toro whatever
the shadow of the shape of water yes the
shape of water that the white male was
just
he's bad there's no good to him he's
just bad if you label them as bad you're
correct
yeah it was no that was definitely
propagandistic movie that movie
in every in so many ways it was
propagandistic uh
and so i think that that's
it's like i also i also don't have a
problem with having uh
a bad character like there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that
but you know if you look at like in lord
of the rings if you look at
a character like gollum for example i
mean that's a great character too
because
he's he's bad he's a bad character but
he's also like an extension of frodo
he you know you you know that he's where
frodo could go
like if he let himself go he could go
there so you can see gollum and frodo
and you can see frodo and golem a little
bit too and so that's a
powerful story because you can you you
have these two characters one which is
like a good character one which is a bad
character
but it's also not just it's not a simple
simple relationship there's a
relationship where
one is like the promise of the other in
a certain manner and so that makes it
far more subtle and far more
engaging in my opinion i was trying to
think of when is it okay to actually
just have a character which you can
outright categorize as bad and i wonder
if it's only when
they are a representation of satan so
like let's say sauron yeah
yeah he's like he's not even embodied
right he's like he's just like a
he's just an idea almost you know i mean
he obviously he's a being but
he's not he's not embodied in the world
they don't encounter sauron you know
he's encountering him through kind of
third second
uh second tiers or whatever um so yeah i
think so maybe that's a good way to
understand it i've actually thought
about sauron quite a bit sometimes about
if
if it's too easy or if that character is
too easy um
but like but then someone could
criticize the bible someone could
criticize the bible and say
jesus is too easy he's too good and the
satan is too bad
he's that's too easy yeah well but it's
like that's the point it's supposed to
be the extreme so maybe it's okay when
it's supposed to be the extreme well the
thing about that people don't underst
that christ does not fit that category
people people don't know the story of
christ or they
you read the story of christ the story
of christ is
the most the most
elated and disturbing story at the same
time
christ says some stuff that people don't
like to cite because
it just if you want to just make christ
into
a simple good guy story it's not that's
not
give us an example christ says i came to
bring fire to the world to turn brother
against brother
christ said on the cross father why did
how why did you abandon me christ said
uh you know christ said to peter bring a
sword
and then when peter takes his sword out
and cuts off the ear of a soldier
he stops and says no don't do that
what i'm saying is that christ is a far
more complex figure than what we want to
believe that he is you know think of
christ think of
crazy story think of christ there as the
rabbi
who is the one who who brings who's
bringing the word and the truth and all
that
and imagine a [ __ ] washing his feet
with perfume
like think of christ as the one who
who who hung out with with uh you know
with samaritans
with strangers and and the marginalized
and all that and that's how the left
want to portray him for example
but then he also goes and hangs out with
a tax collector who's basically
a uh who's basically a a
a a stooge for the romans who's uh who's
basically a tool of the
of the empire to control us and so
christ goes
all directions christ goes in every
direction it's like you
you re once if you understand the types
that that are in
that are in stories and you read
christ's story you know i've read i've
read scholars complained that
we don't know how to how to to frame
christ because he's a he's a
he's a teacher but he's he's like a
rabbi figure he's also like a prophet
figure
but then he's also like the son of uh of
a
worker he's also he's also like a
woodworker he's also
uh you know he hangs out with fishermen
then he
talks to and it's like all he he he kind
of fills up
all the stories and so
and so that's why that's the story of
christ is very
it's it's very difficult to well getting
back to propagandistic
this is what's interesting because it's
not simple
it's not true you can't frame this
person as good or bad now that's
standard in screenwriting
never make your protagonist purely good
never make your antagonist purely bad
can we go a little bit beyond that as to
how can we stop ourselves from
consciously trying to push a message
yeah well i mean i think that i think
that this simple way
there's ways that have been told to us
forever i mean just aristotle told us
maybe give your characters a fatal flaw
like it's not a it's not it's not it's
not a mystery you know give them
something that could destroy them you
know and either it does or it doesn't
but make sure that it's there
that your even your hero has uh has a fl
had something that
could devour them um and i would say the
same for your enemy right make your
enemies convincing make them
make them a twisted version of something
true
right don't just make them a random bad
guy who you know if you make them
a twisted understanding of something of
something which it actually has value
then then those that makes for powerful
bad guys like
for example the the in the last avengers
movie the thanos character
that was a great character he's a great
evil character
because he actually he actually talks
about
things that people care about today he
talks about ecological disaster he talks
about
you know all the things that even the
left cares about but then he pushes it
to such an extreme that you kind of shy
away from it because it's like okay
okay where are you going with this you
know versus the shape of water which is
like the shape of water is just trash
it's a trash movie
because it's because it it doesn't
i mean in every single way like there's
so many ways in which the shape of water
is trash because it
it just it's almost like a cliche it's
like it's almost a cliche of of you
could guess
each character what's going to happen to
them you know when it when it starts
and uh you know the there's oh there's
some there's some
especially the bad guy that that that
the bad guy in the movie
some of the things he says that are so
bad in terms of
they're so obvious that it hurts what is
it there's one scene
when he says something he goes to the
bathroom and he says you can learn a lot
about a man whether he washes his hands
before after or after and i'm like oh my
goodness like this
and you don't you don't do it twice
because that shows weakness yeah it's
like you're so
obvious you know you're so obvious about
him being you know excessive purity and
all that stuff
but yeah it's this part for the course
by now it's non-stop you know there's
this movie coming out
just now what's it called it's like
these monstrous dolls and
you know it's just not
i mean we've kind of swallowed this this
thing right now this is
this is this is where society is going
in this direction i don't know where
it's going to lead because it
can't sustain itself you can't
you can't have a world of exceptions do
you see hollywood contributing to this
problem oh for sure
since the beginning i think i think that
i think that
this problem of polarization or this
problem of what
the thing is that it it falls into the
it's a problem of entertainment culture
itself
that's a problem we the idea that our
cultural
rep our cultural artifacts are
entertainment
that's a problem we don't we don't we
don't realize that it's it's it's
basic it comes back to what i talked to
at first when i talked about art
when i told you that that traditional
art
integrates in us in a culture right
so traditional uh storytelling
was part of festivals was part of of uh
you know gathering around the campfire
and telling the story of our
ancestors it was about you know putting
on masks and
and and wearing the costumes and playing
out the these characters
but in a manner in which we're
participating in it we're so we're doing
it on this date because it's
it's re it's to remember something that
happened you know there's a shared
there's a shared principle united under
purpose
yeah purpose and and and just the fact
that we're together all of this comes
together
and so the problem is that now
almost all our cultural artifacts are
there to
entertain us they're there to they're
like a giant circus
our culture the last the last remaining
cultural artifact we have is basically a
circus
it's there to it's just there for for uh
to uh to keep us distracted
okay last question when do you see the
left going too far
i think i think the left the purpose of
the left is to ask
questions you could say is to say what
about this right
so you have some identity it doesn't
matter what it is and then the right
hand's like this
and then the left hand's like well yeah
what about this what about that like how
does
like the role of the skeptic yeah like
how does this fit you know and
and why doesn't this fit and what did
you think about this you know it's like
oh yeah you say
you say this but you're leaving this
aside right you're not considering this
and so in society that ends up being
exactly
kind of what we see which is this like
oh you forgot the exception don't forget
the exception
there's your rule but there's also
exception some people don't fit
so you have to you have to remember them
don't forget the exception
you know the problem happens when we try
to
make the exception the norm it doesn't
work
you can't have a world of exceptions it
just doesn't exist
it can't exist it just it crumbles and
so
i think that that's the problem that we
have now is that
we want we went from wanting to care for
marginalized identities
to this the the idea that somehow
an accumulation of marginalization will
make you into a
heroic figure that doesn't doesn't
doesn't do that
does it just because you are
marginalized
doesn't make you pure like it's like
it's like you're flipping it upside down
it's like the identitarians are saying
just because i am of this group
i'm fine just because i am you know
white or i'm
i'm a man or i'm this just because of
that then
i'm sufficient and i'm fine
it's like i'm pure right that's that's
the bad
but but now what we have this weird
crazy left is the very same thing just
upside down
there's it's like it's like a
competition of purity but like a
competition of exception
if you can be the most exceptional in
the sense that you are the most
marginalized then then you
you're playing the same purity game just
upside down
it doesn't work you need you need the
two like you need you need
you need the the statement of of
identity and then you need
things that are there on the on the
margin which say hey
hey don't don't think you've got
everything because i'm here to show you
that you haven't accounted for
everything right you haven't accounted
for everything
and i think that that's that's the
normal balance
you know all right man
thank you so much well i hope i hope it
was useful
let's see what it looks like
you